اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
ومداهمات في مناطق متفرقه من الضفه
الغربيه ما ادى الى استشهادي شاب فلسطيني
خلال اقتحام مخيم قلنديا كما اصيب 10
اخرون خلال عمليه التسلل لجنود الاحتلال
في البلده القديمه
توافق امريكي ياباني على تعزيز التعاون
الامني واشنطن اكدت التزامها بالدفاع عن
طوكيو بكل عناصر القوه بما فيها النوويه
بينما وصفت اليابان الصين بالتحدي
الاستراتيجي في حين دعت الصيل لضروره عدم
اضرار التعاون العسكري الياباني بمصالح اي
طرف ثالث
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقول ان متحولا
جديدا قد يكون المتسببه في زياده حالات
الاصابه بفايروس كورونا ولكنها اشارت الى
وجود ثقه منخفضه في التقييم لان اغلب
البيانات مستمده من دوله واحده فقط وهي
الولايات المتحده
البيتكوين تحقق اطول فتره من المكاسب منذ
2020 وذلك لتسعه ايام متتاليه حيث صعدت
العمله اكثر من 10% الشهر الحالي بعد موجه
تراجعات بلغت اكثر من 60 وسط سلسله ازمات
مرت بها العمله المشفره